je suis désolé mais je suis vraiment
très très désolé mais je crois que ça va
être mon tour je vois du Tron scène
direct plus orchestre Paris
s'éveille
merci merci merci papa merci
papa nous y allons 1 2 1 2 3
4 je suis le dauphin de la Place
Dauphine et la Place Blanche à
mauvaiseine
les camions sont pleins de lait les
balayeurs sont pleins de B il est
Paris
[Applaudissements]
s
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Paris les travestis vont se raser
sont
les traversins sont écrasés les amourux
sont fatigués il est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
5h le café dans les tasses les cafés les
toil
glace et surou par mon Parnasse la gare
est plus qu'une carcasse il est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Paris les pard sont dans les la
VAN
par les boulangers les Bâ il
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
5 la tour est fait la FR au pied de
Triomphe
ranimé qui est bien dressé entre la nuit
et la
journée
5h
Paris
ser
[Musique]
Paris les journaux sont imprimés les
ouvriers sont
déprimés les gens se lève ils sont
brimés c'est l'heure où je vais me
coucher il est
5h Paris
séveil il est
5h je n'ai pas
se